THE PRESIDENT SAID ABOUT IT
ABOUT THE ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
BUT JUST IN THE PAST FEW
MINUTES "THE WASHINGTON
POST" HAS MOVED A PIECE THAT
SAYS THE CIA CONCLUDES SAUDI
CROWNED PRINCE ORDERED JAMAL
KHASHOGGI'S ASSASSINATION
THE SAUDI JOURNALIST KILLED
IN THE SAUDI CONSULATE IN
ISTANBUL.
IF TRUE, AND WE HAVEN'T
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRMED
THIS, ONE WOULD THINK THERE
IS A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF DIFFERENT ANSWER,
JONAH?
>> YEAH.
I IMAGINE DONALD TRUMP IS
HAVING AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION ABOUT MIKE
POMPEO ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
AND I THINK IT SHOULD PROMPT
A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THE
WAY WE HAVE DEALT WITH THE
SAUDIS.
THIS WAS A PLANNED
ASSASSINATION FROM THE TOP
IN POWER IN SAUDI ARABIA.
YOU CAN'T SAY WE HAVE TO
PROTECT OUR INTEREST AND
DEFINE OUR INTERESTS SOLELY
AS ARM SALES.
WE HAVE OTHER INTERESTS
INCLUDING THE RULE OF LAW
AND THE IDEA THAT YOU ARE
NOT SUPPOSED TO MURDER
JOURNALISTS WHO ARE
INCONVENIENT.
>> Bret: QUICKLY, SUSAN?
>> I'M NOT SURPRISED BUT
CERTAINLY PUTS PRESSURE ON
THE ADMINISTRATION TO DO
MORE THAN IT'S DONE TO
RESPOND TO THIS.
>> YEAH, I TOTALLY CONCUR
WITH THE TWO OF THEM.
AND I THINK IT'S ALMOST TIME
TO RELOOK AT OUR MIDDLE EAST
POLICY, YOU KNOW, AT LARGE.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SEE
JUST, YOU KNOW, THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE STILL OUT OF SYRIA.
STILL CAN'T GET INTO THEIR
HOMES.
NO RESOLUTION THERE.
AS WE SORT OF PIVOT TO CHINA